we'd like to think that there is some
kind of burden of proof the facts matter
that the law matters that the
Constitution matters but these
politicians can make up the decision any
way they want to and for many of them is
just about will they be able to keep
their jobs if they make it one way or
another will they be reelected or not
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special today we're
joined by attorney Gloria Allred
Gloria's been a women's rights and
discrimination lawyer for 44 years she's
been involved in many high-profile cases
she's the subject of the Netflix
documentary seeing all red get it seeing
all the the national trial lawyers have
recognized her with the Lifetime
Achievement Award for her battles
against injustice for women and
minorities and Gloria was also recently
inducted into the women's Hall of Fame
Gloria thanks so much for stopping by I
really very much for inviting me Ben
well in just a second I'm going to start
asking you questions but first reminder
we'll be doing some bonus questions you
only get to ask if you are a subscriber
head on over to daily wire.com become a
subscriber you'll have access to all of
the full conversations with every one of
our awesome
guess also it is the holiday season and
you know what that means it's time to
think of your upcoming death well
actually if you don't feel like thinking
about your own death probably you should
just think about life insurance and then
you don't have to think about death
anymore
see here's the thing if you go over to
policy genius.com they'll find you the
right life insurance at the best price
and do all the work to help you get
covered policy genius makes finding the
right life insurance a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers and find your best price you
could say 1500 bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy that can also help you find the
right home and auto insurance disability
insurance so if you need life insurance
but you aren't sure where to start why
not start at policy genius calm or
competitive shopping can help you it
only takes a few minutes to find the
right life insurance policy apply across
another thing off that holiday to-do
list policy genius when it comes to life
insurance it is nice to get it right and
then you have to think about plowing
anymore because if God forbid something
happens to your family is taking care of
go check them out of policy genius.com
again that's policy genius.com so again
thanks so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it
thank you so for those of us who aren't
familiar with sort of how you got to
where you are like my first familiarity
with you is not just you were on KBC and
I used to listen to KABC out here in Los
Angeles for years but also my sister's
favorite movie was rat race and so your
cameo in rat race was definitely the
first time I'd ever actually seen you so
how did you get to be gloria allred
well I there were very few women's
rights lawyers when I started out in the
70s and the National Organization for
Women asked me to
to be the president of the Los Angeles
Chapter essentially because I did care
about women's rights and also no one
else would do it at the time no one else
wanted to be called a feminist and so I
did that and then I decided that because
I was blessed to become a lawyer there
were very few women lawyers at the time
93% of my law school class but there
were men that I felt that I had a duty
to give back and at least do some cases
that would help women to assert their
rights and vindicate their rights in a
court of law and so I took on some cases
and the more cases that I took the more
people wanted to come to me also because
we were developing and expertise in
those cases and almost nobody else would
take those cases so we began to do
sexual harassment and employment cases
pregnancy discrimination sex
discrimination rape sexual assault child
sexual abuse cases for plaintiffs that
is for victims and so that's how we
became the leading women's rights law
firm in the United States which we have
been for 44 years so historically have
you chosen your clients cuz obviously
you've had an enormous number of
high-profile clients you've been very
present in the media how do you choose
which clients you you want to focus in
on very carefully we get requests for
representation from almost every state
in the United States and sometimes from
women living abroad or minorities living
abroad and so we have to be very
selective and we screen and we vet we're
probably more conservative than the most
conservative judges in the case that
cases that we ultimately choose in other
words we want to make sure that there's
a probability of success that it's
within our area of expertise we have to
look at the evidence that they have the
timeliness of the case
and the client and what their goals are
and whether these are achievable goals
or not so we we do screen very very
carefully if we cannot assist someone at
our law firm which is Allred Morocco and
Goldberg and we have offices in New York
and
Los Angeles I'm licensed in both states
as well as being licensed in Washington
DC but if we cannot assist them we will
try to provide them with a referral
because we'd like everyone to be able to
have access to justice so in terms of
sort of the big public debate that's
been happening over me too and there
have been so many high-profile cases
regarding sexual harassment or sexual
assault and in the recent past how do
you determine credibility issues so one
of the things that we've heard a lot
from the media is and there's a hashtag
that's been trending very very
prominently they believe all women
movement and you know as a lawyer myself
I've always thought that doesn't make a
lot of sense in the sense that lots of
people don't tell the truth you know
obviously the percentages are not great
in terms of women who are lying about
something bad happening to them but how
do you determine what amounts to a
credible accusation and what amounts to
a non credible accusation well we look
at all the evidence not just the word of
the person who wishes to be our client
but also you know is there some sort of
corroboration for example if there's a
rape have they told anyone of us what we
call it a spontaneous or contemporaneous
al cry soon after or at any point prior
to their coming to us have they told a
friend a family member a co-worker a
therapist a doctor who a priest a rabbi
a minister who have they told anyone has
there been any documentary evidence has
there been emails have there been texts
have what other kind of evidence exists
so there are a lot of things to consider
it's not just a question of whether we
believe them it's a question of
evaluating the evidence and do we think
that a judge or a jury would likely find
in their favor
and of course we do a lot of
confidential settlements without any
litigation as well and so there's a lot
to consider
I will say that fortunately we just won
I mean probably possibly the biggest
sexual harassment verdict ever in the
United States we haven't found anyone
that's larger it we won for our client
Mahim con a verdict by a Los Angeles
County Superior Court jury
who found that alkie David who is a
billionaire and who was the defendant in
our case that the jury found in Mahim
favor and came back with an award of
compensatory damages eight million two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
punitive damages damages to punish mr.
David of fifty million dollars and so
for a total of fifty eight million two
hundred fifty thousand dollars so again
we haven't found any larger verdict ever
in a sexual harassment case for one
victim against one employer and just
prior to that case within the month
my partner's also tried another case
against mr. David again another victim
who alleged sexual harassment and in
that case the jury came back with five
million dollars verdict in favor of our
client Lauren Reeves against mr. David
so he's now owing us once all the
judgments were entered in excess of 63
million dollars and of course I have
also gone to the Beverly Hills Police
Department on behalf of and accompanied
by Rahim Khan and asked them to open now
a criminal investigation into a mr.
David so we'll see what happens but we
are looking for accountability from
perpetrators who inflict and justices on
our clients some most of whom are women
but we also represent a lot of men who
are victims of sexual harassment and we
have won victories for them and also of
course we represent minorities who are
discriminated against or in some way
hurt either because of their sexual
orientation because people perceive they
have AIDS or HIV or in fact they do have
AIDS or HIV and so because everybody
should be treated equally everybody
should be treated with respect and
dignity and everybody should be afforded
their rights and there's no point in
having rights that on the books that
people have marched for a lobbied for
testified for and sacrifice for if
there's no way to enforce those rights
oh then we're like private attorney
generals
our private law firm and we go about
enforcing those rights and when it comes
to this corpus of law do you think that
there is any economic downside for some
of the groups that are specifically
being protected by the law so this
argument has been made before by
libertarians particularly ok where they
say let's say you have laws that are on
the books to protect women against
sexual harassment and so employers
decide they don't want to face the
possibility of liability and so they're
less likely to hire a woman have you
what what do you make of the argument
that the the best remedy to some of this
is to basically work for companies where
men are not going to be pigs as opposed
to legal remedies that that create an
entire risk liability scenario for
companies that may be willing to treat
women fine but now are afraid of the
possibility of legal action in the
future well of course then they can be
charged with sex discrimination right of
course and so that's kind of a no-win
situation for them I would say the best
option for companies is just to monitor
your workplace I'll educate people about
the policy of the company and the law of
the United States which is Equal
Employment Opportunity and it should not
be any sexual harassment on the job
because that's considered generally sex
discrimination and sex discrimination
interferes with the the right the law
which mandates that a person has the
right to equal employment opportunity so
I think that you know what he should
take this to extremes
sexual harassment does interfere with
Equal Employment Opportunity but the
answer is not sex discrimination
excluding a class of people solely on
account of their gender the answer is
just make your workplace a workplace and
not something that is interfered with by
placing people in a no-win situation
where if they say yes to sexual
harassment later the guy or whoever's
harassing them may get tired of them and
then they lose their job or if they say
no then that person who's the employer
may go into ego shock because they said
no they didn't want to go around along
with it so you know it's is this doable
by employers if they want to make a
doable and if they don't then they do
risk lawsuits and so there is a cost for
them
and it's better for them just to make
sure their workplace is not hostile or
toxic because of sexual harassment or
race discrimination sex discrimination
discrimination on account of sexual
orientation or in or age or any other
reason and and that way they can have
their workers do what they were hired to
do just do your job so you play sort of
a dual role in the American public
obviously your high profile lawyer
winning these big cases on the other
hand you also are commenting publicly on
sort of issues of the day the nice thing
about the legal sphere is at least there
seems to be maybe it's not always
applied but it's sort of standard so for
example you have to you have to by a
preponderance of the evidence prove a
charge or beyond a reasonable doubt in
criminal cases prove the charge or for
punitive damages damages to punish
because it shocks the conscience of the
community there's a different standard
clear and convincing evidence right so
and so that's higher than preponderance
lower than there but lower than beyond a
reasonable doubt so the but but in the
in the public mind when it comes to a
lot of these cases which sort of hit you
know the front pages and then the public
is asked to make decisions about them
and here I'm thinking specifically about
for example the nomination of justice
Cavanaugh where that was not a criminal
trial but in that particular case this
became a very hot button issue for all
of the United States and there was no
clear standard as to what sort of
evidence was necessary in order for
people to convict or not convict in the
mind of the public so not just with
specific to to Cavanaugh but generally
what do you think you know as somebody
who litigates in this area what do you
think the American public they see a
charge on the front page what do you
think is the standard of evidence that
we should apply in our own mind when we
determine is an accusation tantamount to
guilt or what sort of evidence should be
necessary in order for us to go along
with the idea that somebody's career for
example should be effective
great question parenthetically I just
had an opportunity to have a chat with
justice Cavanaugh at a reception at the
Supreme Court to which I was invited but
of course I didn't talk about the
allegations that were made against him
nor would I ever say what he said to me
it's a I've also met other justices of
the Supreme Court and had a chance to
chat with them so I don't I don't talk
about what they said but in any event
what it should be this day
in the political setting is exactly what
you're asking and it's pretty much the
same standard as applies to your show
and people who watch it or listen to it
or both and anything on the internet
which is everything goes in the court of
public opinion and there is no standard
there is no burden of proof people can
reach a conclusion without any facts
whatsoever or with just using the facts
they choose to recognize or acknowledge
or with no fact however they want to
it's not like a court of law and that is
important also on the impeachment issue
and because people say oh it's not like
a court it's not like a trial but this
is happening that's not happening well
because it's not a court
it's just political theater and
political decision-making and that's
just the way I mean the Constitution has
it it's a political body that is going
to be making these decisions and so for
their purposes the politicians purposes
is anything goes we'd like to think that
there is some kind of burden of proof
the facts matter that the law matters
that the constitution matters but these
politicians can make up the decision any
way they want to and for many of them
it's just about will they be able to
keep their jobs if they make it one way
or another will they be re-elected or
not so in a second I want to ask you
about the the role of television and
media in the justice system generally
but first what kind of earbuds are you
using to listen to this riveting program
well if you are listening on those
old-fashioned earbuds along with the
wires and you take them out and you put
them in your pocket and when you take
them out again they're all tangled up
like a bird's nest and it takes a half
an hour to untangle them why don't you
have wireless earbuds what are you
living in 1992 well instead of getting
the really expensive wireless earbuds
you should try ray cons ray con just
released their best model yet the e25
there's six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass a more
compact design that gives you a nice and
noise-isolating fit ray cons wireless
earbuds are so comfortable they're
perfect for on-the-go listening for
taking phone calls as well that noise
isolation it works great when you have
small children I know listen ray con
wireless earbuds these things
they sound great they're not gonna cost
you a fortune also they have a variety
of fence if you got a weird ear then
it's a really good piece of machinery
unlike some of your other Wireless
options rake on earbuds are both stylish
and discreet no dangling wires no stems
you've heard me talk about how the
company was co-founded by Ray J other
celebrities are obsessed with Ray cons
pick some up a trach on Comm now's the
time to get the latest and greatest from
Ray Khan get 15% off your order at buy
rake on Comm slash bun that is buy rake
on Comm slash man for 15% off rake on
wireless earbuds be yra y co n comm
slash panic and they're really
comfortable they're high-quality and
you're not gonna spend a fortune by rake
on comm / pen for 15% off and get rid of
those holds your buds they're not gonna
do you any good buy rake on comm / Ben
for 15% off okay so let's talk a little
bit about the fact that as an incredibly
high profile attorney you're on TV a lot
and the big critique that's been
launched against you typically is that
you are looking for attention that
you're looking for cameras what role
should publicity play in judicial
proceedings because obviously when you
are attempting to mobilize public
opinion in a particular case and this
does make a difference you need the
cameras there so in an ideal world what
role would media play and in the real
world what role does the media play okay
well it's not about publicity at all
it's about coverage of important issues
of our time issues that are a public
interest or public importance or both
and also I'm not a person who believes
that women and minorities should suffer
in silence I believe that what they are
suffering the wrongs against them
injustice is against them in certain
cases if they achieve the goals of the
client or can help to achieve those
goals should be made public so yes I
know that certain people who are in
power would not like those who are not
in power to speak out about the wrongs
that have been inflicted on them but I
do think it's important for elected
officials and for members of the public
to know because we need to establish and
create a climate of opinion that is
favorable to change and I do believe
what Gandhi said that we must be the
change we wish to see in the world and
so my clients often want to speak truth
to power and by
speaking to truth to power they are also
not only empowering themselves but
they're empowering many others who are
in similar situations to speak out so
for example in the Jeffrey Epstein case
where I represent a number of accusers
of Jeffrey Epstein and we have filed to
date three lawsuits for our clients who
were underage when they alleged that
they were sexually abused and sexually
trafficked by Jeffrey Epstein so when
they want to speak out they should have
that right to speak out and that also
encourages others just to know what
their rights are perhaps to assert their
rights perhaps to vindicate their rights
and courts of law so no they shouldn't
have to be silenced the victims of
Harvey Weinstein if they can prove that
they are victims they can speak their
truth and they should be able to speak
out and we have with a number of persons
who allege they're victims of Harvey
Weinstein by the way the trials starting
the criminal trial January 6 I represent
one of the two victims for whom charges
have been filed
by the Manhattan DA's office and I also
represent another witness in the case a
novella Shora who will testify on the
issue of sexually predatory conduct so
yeah I think that they should be able to
make known what they allege has happened
to them likewise in the case of our
Kelly well I also represent a number of
accusers and I represent the majority of
the persons who are alleged to be
victims in the criminal case now pending
against him in New York brought by the
United States Justice Department for the
Eastern District of New York and they've
been very brave and many of those women
some of whom are african-american were
ignored for a long time I don't know if
was because they were african-american
perhaps but yes they have their right to
speak truth to power in this case power
is a powerful celebrity or Kelly just
like I represented 33 users in Bill
Cosby he's now where he belongs
convicted of indecent sexual assault
against Audria constant and he is now
classified as a sexually violent
predator here you've got a celebrity who
was you know how to very admit maybe he
had the highest friendly public rating Q
rating they call it television when he
was doing his show in the 90s and yet
now you know he says he's a political
prisoner I said he's not Nelson Mandela
he's just a convicted felon a convicted
sexual predator
so but you know speed takes courage to
speak out to a powerful figure like Bill
Cosby or our Kelly
Jeffrey Epstein when he was alive but
even now when there's an investigation
of whether anyone conspired with mr.
Epstein to sexually traffic underage
girls and also in reference to mr.
Weinstein who was a very powerful
producer in Hollywood but this is what's
happening and women are becoming
empowered they're equalizing the power
and that's important so now what we've
done now in this me to era which is a
form of The Reckoning is you know
instead of the victims waking up in fear
now often the men who have hurt them
every day wake up and like oh my god is
this the day where the women I've hurt
in the past are going to speak out and
my career is going to be ruined or in
shambles good
let them be fearful of that you know
maybe they should reconsider in the
future do they want to continue hurting
women and now maybe they better think
twice about it because there can be
serious consequences well as an
out-and-proud prude and religious Jew
I'm very much in favor of men treating
women with tremendous respect and
ensuring that women's boundaries are
upheld what are the boundaries and what
should the boundaries be when it comes
to me too because we've seen some some
interesting cases where the boundary
seem to have been blurred the one that
comes to mind off the top my head is the
Aziz Ansari case he's on saris this
famous comedian and there's this big
report that a woman goes on a date with
him basically it sounds like a date that
goes wrong it's covered widely in the
media it's seen as a me-too moment and
now as he's unsorted on the hook and
there have been a lot of men who are
complaining that the boundaries of meets
who are not clear that well they're very
much in favor
the Harvey Weinstein's were clearly
abusing women and and the and and the
Jeffrey Epstein's who are clearly
engaged in in rape and sexual abuse and
even cases like some of the ones that
you've that you've moved forward with on
sexual harassment well they're very much
in favor of clear evidence of sexual
harassment and sexual abuse being being
prosecuted or sued upon they don't know
where the limiting principle is with
regard to how to behave toward women now
is that a subjective thing or do you
think there's an actual objective
standard as to when a meet in activity
belongs in the category of me to and
when a category does not belong in the
category of me to well we only take
cases where we think you know there is
severe or pervasive sexual harassment or
sexual battery or to simple battery so
for example what the jury heard in our
case against Alki David the billionaire
the case which we just won
you know they heard testimony about mr.
David allegedly taking my clients head
and driving her by the neck and forcing
her head down towards his penis they
heard testimony about you know other
unconsented to behavior that would
constitute sexual battery some of and
there's some that I can't even say on
the air that is so disgusting that it
happened in the workplace so where are
the boundaries I would say to the men
you could consult the law that's a good
place to start for what boundaries are
in case you don't know that you should
not force a woman's face onto your penis
again these are areas where there should
be broad agreement yeah no but I'm just
saying in case you didn't know that in
case you shouldn't take a woman's
breasts and pop them out of her
brassiere and then take your bare hand
and place it on it in the workplace
guess what that is against the law okay
that would be a sexual battery if proven
and I could go on okay so I do think
that most men know where the boundaries
are but you know what their gamble
they decided hey I'm gonna do it maybe
they've even rationalized in their head
hey I can do it she likes it ok in the
workplace if it's not welcome it's not
even a question of consent the workplace
not welcome and there's a power
differential you need to be very very
careful I would say if you're not sure
err on the side of caution
don't touch a woman period is she's not
your wife but even then she needs to be
able to consent or don't touch a man
unless he consents if she's under the
influence of alcohol if she's under the
influence of drugs or both don't try to
guess whether she's consenting to being
sexually touched by you if she can't she
can't consent as bill cosby found out
under the influence of drugs there's no
power to consent because she's under the
influence of drugs or alcohol or both so
just don't get involved in sexual
activity with her until she's at a point
where she could consent so yeah be
careful at just even asking me the
question is is going to help a man and
don't just give yourself the answers
that you want to hear you know what the
answer is
if you're not if you're in doubt just
assume it's a no so in a second I want
to ask you about obviously your you've
been a formative voice in American
feminism over the last 40 years 50 years
and I want to ask you what feminism
means what it doesn't mean in just one
second first every so often there's a
natural disaster in the United States
and you see all of the horrific tape you
know people who weren't prepared for the
natural disaster and sometimes the
government can't get to you and you see
all of the supermarket shelves and
they're empty and you wonder how are
people taking care of themselves well
don't be one of those people instead
check out wise company wise company
takes an innovative approach in
providing dependable simple affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness an ounce or use wise
company meals are designed to protect
your most valuable asset your family
when government resources are strained
it could be days if not weeks before you
can get some fresh food or water
you really can't rely on somebody else
you have to rely on yourself the
government says this the government says
you should have enough food in your home
to make sure that you are taking care of
in case of an emergency you can't know
what tomorrow may bring
but you can have peace of mind knowing
that you'll be ready with everything you
need don't put yourself in this
situation where you need something you
don't have get prepared today wise food
makes it super easy to get prepared you
just go over to their website you check
them out and you get all the products
that you need you don't have to worry
about it anymore
this week my listeners can get any wise
emergency or outdoor food product and an
extra 25% off the lowest mark price at
wise food storage comm / apparel plus
shipping is free Wise has a 90 day no
questions asked return policy so no risk
in taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family more prepared today
that's wise food storage comm / Shapiro
again wise food storage comm / capiro
and get 25% off and free shipping any
wise emergency or outdoor food product
so you've obviously been a very active
feminist for a long time there there are
various sort of definitions of feminism
that float around you know I give you a
symbol once if your dictionary I'd be
happy to hear them because there's kind
of first wave feminism there second wave
well I don't get involved how many waves
I get involved in how many in Justices
alright so a feminist is simply a person
who believes in legal economic social
and political equality for women with
men are you a feminist been by that's -
sure
that's it thank you I rest my case okay
but the problem is that it's not quite
as simple as all of that
I wish it were quite as simple as all of
that right I mean and you'd be
hard-pressed to find many people in
America who would say no to that
question but obviously there's
widespread disagreement about where the
lines are drawn well it's not to be a
disagreement just go to the dictionary
and then ask yourself how would you want
your daughter to be treated and most
people when they think especially
fathers when they think about how they
would like their daughter to be treated
without going into well what's the
definition of feminism they want their
daughter to be treated with respect with
dignity not to become a victim of gender
violence not to be paid less than men
not to be treated in a way that would
constitute sexual harassment not to be
discriminated against if they become
pregnant well that's really what
feminists believe so among other things
you know not to have a problem
collecting their child support if
somehow the marriage breaks up or there
is no marriage
and so just think about it if you had
daughters or plan to have daughters how
you'd want them to be treated and then
you're probably a feminist I have
fathers that come up to me all the time
if I'm walking down the street or
elsewhere and say thank you we know
you're doing this for our daughters so
it may not agree with everything you say
Gloria but I know that's what you're
trying to do and I appreciate that so
how should feminism view the institution
of marriage if you look at some of the
more famous feminist writers the betty
ford anne's of the world for example
they're very critical in the institution
of marriage seeing it as a sort of
patriarchal imposition on women how
should how should feminists see marriage
well actually marriage the institution
of marriage was begun because men wanted
to know who their children were because
they didn't know if it was their
children or somebody else's children if
the wife or the their significant other
became pregnant and this is when women
were considered property so they made
rules marriage okay then she's mine no
other man better to disturb her because
if they do you know it might be that
they would get her pregnant he wouldn't
know who his children were so but in any
event people can get married or not
getting married
I that's up to them I I'm not going to
criticize that I do think that people
should treat each other as equal
partners if they are married not a
master/slave relationship
not one person dominating the other
person and if people treat each other as
best friends as equal partners and they
have good communication and they are
fair with each other and honest with
each other then it's going to work and
if they're not one person starts to lie
or you know do things they shouldn't
with someone else after they made a
commitment taking a vow for better for
worse a lot of people think it's just
for better but it's better or worse and
then ultimately you know they it's
probably going to work but it's very
difficult to be married these days
because we live in a very mobile society
where people move around they change
careers
sometimes they have other people in
their life as you know as intimate
partners it's it's very challenging but
I think people
generally start out with good intentions
and sometimes to kind of duty rates from
there on a philosophical level there's
been sort of an interesting conversation
about with regard to feminism when it
when it speaks for the Equality of women
does does that mean the Equality or does
it mean the sameness between men and
women meaning take sex equality it's all
about that's why I said equal it's about
improving the condition of status of
women to help to bring women into the
mainstream of American life in equal
partnership so men taking each and every
aspect of life we don't have an equal
number of women elected to Congress or
to the United States get more women than
men going to law school and more women
going to college okay well that's good
for you know it's the beginning
it hasn't there not an equal number of
women as partners and law firms and
partners are the ones who make the
decisions as to which case I mean a lot
of women are making the choice to take
time out of the workforce to have
children my wife is a doctor she's taken
time off twice to have kids okay well
you know that's your choice that's her
choice I agree and and that is reflected
in aggregate statistics
okay well that isn't the reason or the
only reason why women don't become
partners in law firms we've had a lot of
cases where we represent know obviously
I'm so good tonight partnerships on
account of their gender having said that
you always have to prove the case which
we're very happy to be able to do so I
mean it's just about treating women with
equal respect and dignity and that's
what it this is about if you do it it's
right and women can be a very big asset
to business and I agree but it'll it to
take a case that's sort of more
controversial so women and men agreed as
far as the the goal of equal treatment
now you have a biological man who wants
to race with women in female sports or
this come up recently in Connecticut is
coming up in the Olympics as well where
do you stand as a feminist on this
question so they're feminists who say
listen women are a category men are a
category men who identify as women are
not in fact biological women and so
having them race now you're talking
about gender evident because because
feminism is why I'm asking the question
between equality and sameness because
obviously either these are malleable
categories are they're not malleable
categories I mean that's a mutually
exclusive proposition so the idea of a
man identifying as a woman for
purposes of competing or generally and
then competing with virtually not
identifying as a woman just for the
purposes agree that's why I amended the
statement so a man who identifies as a
woman because he believes he is a woman
and he is competing with women as a
feminist is that something that you are
pro or against not only believes that
self identifies and perhaps should be
considered should be considered well now
you're making a moral ok bra does not
know I'm also making a legal drawing a
legal conclusion but let me get back to
the heart of your question it's a
challenging line it's a difficult one I
represent it by the way a transgender
woman you know I'm aware of this case
case against Trump before he became
president and she was once someone sent
an anonymous tip to the Miss Universe
Miss Canada pageant that she was going
to be in that in fact she was born with
a male anatomy
then they excluded her for the pageant
which Trump owned but then of course I
raised that issue in a significant
manner and mr. Trump and I just kind of
kept challenging mr. Trump on it
challenging him on it appeared on 20/20
or Barbara Walters special and in bottom
line is he ended up putting her back in
and they eliminated the rule which I
wanted them to eliminate you have to be
a naturally born female to be in a
pageant but having said that in his
pageant but the point is it is very
difficult where it comes to sports but I
just don't think anyone should be denied
the opportunity to compete solely on
account of their gender or because they
are transgender and it's just difficult
but I think that's the way it is so I
don't want to deny anybody an
opportunity so so why does self-identity
make a difference there meaning if a man
just wants to compete in a female's pour
why should he not be able to why should
the self-identity be the deciding factor
well again that's a hard one I don't
really have an answer it's some kind of
thinking about it myself but I
you know in certain sports it would give
an advantage to the men and deny had an
opportunity to women so the similar
question yes at that point it may be
that that it makes sense to deny a man
to be in a woman's for it but you take
public education for example I went to
an all-girls high school back in the
cave age when I went to an all-boys high
school much younger okay and but that's
a publicly funded high school it was in
Philadelphia still is and I we didn't
have really there were men didn't want
to be poor boys didn't want to be in it
at the time or girls high school because
women were considered of less value some
of the girls decided they wanted to go
to the all-boys high school also
publicly funded men being considered of
more value may be having more programs
there maybe it was better funded because
after all there were men considered to
be more important than women there have
been court challenges and since then the
courts have decided that yes boys should
have the opportunity to go to girls hi
girls should have the opportunity to go
to Central High School which was the
all-boys high school in Philadelphia
both top schools so is there any area of
American life where you believe that
there should be the ability to have a
female only space or a male only space
and there there's pretty good evidence
to suggest that for example women if
girls tend actually do better in girls
only classes because thanks to in many
cases sort of patriarchal view of boys
women actually perform better when they
are not confronted with there's some
evidence of that I would have to agree
with you on that and I would say if it's
completely private that they have the
right to do it if however they accept
any taxpayer funds they don't have the
right to do it so you're not talking
about a lesser quality of education for
the girls though you're actually talking
about I'm talking about even in the
public saluting someone on account of
their gender that they shouldn't be able
to do that if they're receiving any
public funds any taxpayer funds at all
so in in a in in a school ok so are you
for the abolition of male and female
bathrooms completely
I mean like there's a prime argument no
but it's a separate sorry by the way I
remember that bathroom argument
presented to me by a judge back in the
70s when I was representing a man in
Santa Monica who wanted to be on the
commission of the status of women and
they only had women who they wanted to
exclude a man and the judge said to me
woman is all red or what about bathrooms
and I said judge there's nothing to do
with bathrooms this has to do with a
commission on the status of women which
is government funded government
supported and therefore they should not
be excluding anyone on account of their
gender like this man that I represent
because I mean men have a stake in the
status and rights and future of women
and so they it should be they should be
able to have access to that opportunity
to be on the Commission on the status of
women I would be remiss if I didn't ask
you about your perspective on abortion
because I want to give you the
opportunity to give a good or choice
favor laughter so we'll talk about that
in just one second first let's talk
about those horrible stories you see on
the news about some celebrity who's been
hacked and other nude photos are out
there so rule number one don't take nude
photos of yourself using a phone I mean
Gloria Allred sitting right here she
will tell you that's probably a bad I
don't know maybe Gloria won't say in any
case make sure secondly that all your
data is protected there are tons of VPN
providers out there you've probably
heard of a couple of them some of you
maybe even used a VPN before expressvpn
does not log at your data lots of really
cheap or free VPNs make money by selling
that data you know the stuff they're
supposed to be protecting to add
companies expressvpn has developed a
technology called trusted server that
makes it impossible for their servers so
I'll get any of your data second they've
got speed I've tried lots of VPNs in the
past many will slow your connection down
make it by sluggish I'm using Express
you can for a couple of years my
internet speeds blazing fast which I
need I run an internet company even when
I connect to servers thousands of miles
away
I can still stream HD quality videos
with zero lag the last thing that really
sets expressvpn apart from other VPNs
it's really easy to use
unlike other VPNs you don't have to
input or program anything you fire up
the app you click one button and you're
connected it's so easy even your
grandparents could use it you will
benefit from expressvpn - they're just
too many people out there who are
looking for your data so protect
yourself with the VPN I use entrust use
my link expressvpn comm slash Ben today
get an extra three months free on
one-year package that's expressvpn comm
slash Ben again expressvpn comm slash
Ben to learn more so gloria allred I
want to ask you about your perspective
on abortion because I've gotten a lot of
people who want me to ask you that
question and I'd love to hear a
perspective also okay so obviously I'm
very pro-life you're very pro-choice so
I wanted to get your take and I know
obviously you have a deeply felt
personal story about how you came to
this conclusion but why are you
pro-choice is approach to polite
pro-life
well I'm pro-choice because I don't
think that the United States government
or for that matter any government should
be making a laws which restrict or
eliminate a woman's right to choose safe
legal affordable available abortions
because when government tries to
restrict or eliminate a woman's right to
choose what they're saying is
essentially that they think they're
saying or maybe they purport to be
saying that a woman should not be able
to get an abortion but of course women
will still continue to get abortions
only they will be illegal unsafe and
many women will die as they did before
roe v-- wade perhaps hemorrhage to death
which I almost did because I had to have
an abortion provided by someone who is
not a licensed healthcare provider
because it was not I was not able
because of the laws to be able to have
access to a licensed healthcare provider
like a doctor to perform an abortion so
many women had what's called back-alley
abortions where they almost bled to
death or were maimed or did die and I
don't want that to happen to anybody
else daughter or sister or mama and the
people who are hurt by these laws
attempting to restrict abortion are
young women poor women rural women and
mainly women of color maybe they can't
afford the bus fare to go to another
state where abortion is still legal
maybe they
even get there because they're working
two jobs or three jobs or have kid other
kids to support
so in other words I don't believe in
mandatory motherhood perhaps like you do
where women are forced to you know take
a fetus to term and deliver I don't
believe that a fertilized egg should
have more rights than than an adult
woman and I think this is all very
dangerous to women's health
it's a hot-button issue for millions of
women around the country do you believe
there should be any period-based
restrictions on abortion or abortion
should be available up to point of birth
I think that roe v wade the 1973 United
States Supreme Court decision which
found that women have a fundamental
constitutional right to choose abortion
at certain stages of their pregnancy
which cannot be interfered with by the
government or anyone else I think that
is a decision which should remain even
though the anti-choice activists want to
try to reverse roe v wade and allow
states to make ridiculous and dangerous
restrictions on abortion once they even
trying to make it abortion illegal for a
woman to try to get one even because
before she's even pregnant no she's
pregnant it's just absurd but worse than
that this is I can't emphasize that
we're dangerous enough and it's it's
wrong and we're going to fight against
it yes I had an abortion when I almost
and I almost died when I was in my 20s
so I know what it's like to be a young
woman doesn't know where to go what to
do and but you know I yes I know I've
seen pictures the protests where there
are a lot of men and teenage teenagers
from certain religious schools out there
protesting I know a fair number woman
well some women too I'm not saying there
are no women but I'm saying I know they
have a 40 so leaves about forcing women
to take pregnancies to turn to term they
say they're pro-life and maybe what
about the life of the mother is my
question or the woman who's carrying a
fetus not aware that anybody's wanting
to
kill it but you know I I just don't
believe anybody should be able to impose
their religious ideology on others who
don't necessarily subscribe to that
those religious beliefs everyone is
entitled to be respected for their
religious beliefs but not to have the
government weaponize those beliefs into
law what about the the scientific life
interest of the fetus what I mean there
is that the I speak to pro-life groups
I'm sure far more often than you do I'm
sure you speak to pro-choice groups far
more often than I do by my converse and
the main argument that I articulate in
that pro-lifers around me articulate is
not a religiously based argument it's an
argument based on the science of fetal
development the question that I'm asking
is even Roe versus Wade acknowledges
that at a certain point in the pregnancy
there is a countervailing interest in
the life of the child do you acknowledge
that there is a countervailing interest
in the life of the child in the
preservation thereof and on what basis
in the fetal development would you place
that countervailing life and I mean how
much do you care about the life of the
woman I care about versus the life of
the fetus or you know the future of the
fetus I care about that slightly more
than the life of the child in that if
the child in danger is the life of the
woman I'm in favor of abortion but that
is the only sort okay well I'm not in
favor of abortion and I'm not in favor
of no horses okay so I'm in favor of
choice I don't think that elected
officials sitting in Washington or
Sacramento or any other capital of any
state who have never met any of these
women who are getting pregnant should be
making a decision for them that is going
to affect their lives that is what's
happening and that is why we have such a
stake in the next election because
whoever is elected as president United
States is going to be able to select or
nominate persons who may be justices on
the United States Supreme Court to fill
vacancies but surely there will be in
the next term and this is some really I
really I promise I'm only gonna ask it
one more time and then I know we have to
run okay if the question again is about
the the life interest of the fetus oh
I'm perfectly willing to acknowledge the
life interest of the mother which is why
again I'm in favor of the possibility of
abortion when a mother's life is in
danger
but do you know that's really big of you
you know because it's about the
definition of life it's not about you
throughout the law it's about what laws
I wasn't the law until 1973 it's about
the law I know because States could
criminalize abortion before that and and
force women to have unsafe illegal
abortions and cuz I'm at 40 alternative
and you are too young to remember what
it was like I'm old enough to know that
there are a million abortions a year
some of it was them you were too young
to know being that you're what 36 to
know what is like before 1973 in the US
Supreme Court decision on abortion and
you don't know and I do how many women
were for had illegal abortions and who
will never tell you they will tell me
and they suffered I'm not willing to
inflict that suffering in that danger
are you on the unborn child on women I
mean is the motor's health have any
interest I keep it's the third time I've
acid yes the third time you've asked
because your priority is the fetus and
not the life of the woman no I've
already acknowledged that I'm in
perfectly in favor okay but worse alone
are not enough no I know the laws we
need laws that protect the right of the
woman to make that choice okay I'm not
going to I'm not going to assist that
every sperm of yours be used okay to
impregnate a woman I'm not even working
I'm not going to present to you I'm just
gonna force you to make women pregnant
is what I'm saying
and I'm not gonna clap it's not gonna
stop you either okay I'm not in favor of
laws which restrict you in two choices
you're gonna make as long as they're
legal in reference to your sexual
activity okay but apparently you want to
pose a whole set of laws on women which
it's going to make them risk their lives
okay so again thank you I respect your
right to want to advocate to restrict a
woman's right to choose and what she
does with her body she's not your body
no it's the baby's body that's not a
baby if it's a fetus that's a fetus you
want to use scientific terms use them
it's called a fetus a wonder woman
for birth to wax it's called a
fertilized egg another boy so you're
getting birth control glasses it's an
embryo then fetus are you are you
against birth control no okay are you
against the morning-after pill yes okay
in other words even if a woman is raped
you want to restrict her ability to
choose to have an abortion is that
correct
if you want to argue about the edge case
in which I don't want to argue about a
question which you've not answered yes
the answer it the answer to restrict the
answer is the answer is yes
morning-after the rapist should be
captured killed put in jail forever and
the babies about the rapist I understand
I'm talking about the woman and the rape
victim does she based on access to a
morning-after the case that you're
making is that based on cases of rape we
should then legalize abortion for all
other cases rape represents an
extraordinarily small number of
abortions each one of those is a
horrific situation a tragedy what do you
even have abortion it's a horrific
situation any time a woman has to make a
decision about whether she's going to
have an abortion or not so we're just
saying that she's the one who gets to
decide why is that so hard for you
because no later knows better than she
does some elected official she's never
met sitting thousands of miles away has
a right to decide what she can do in her
own life what that teenager has a right
to do what that woman living in a rural
area has a right to do what that woman
of color has the right to do what that
poor woman has the right to do because
again you refuse to acknowledge that
there's a countervailing interest in
this equation apparently does not exist
of interest where the United States
Supreme Court comes to it as always
trying to balance interests okay there
the court they made their decision in 73
ever since people are trying to reverse
it cut back on it why mainly for
political reasons but I don't think it
won't of a woman should be a political
football okay so obviously been
following impeachment proceedings since
the Clinton days I want to ask you
whether you think President Trump
merits impeachment or whether the
evidence just isn't there if you want to
hear Gloria Allred's answer you have to
be a deadly wire subscriber to subscribe
head on over to
we're calm click subscribe you can hear
the end of our conversation there well I
know that you have to run I really do
appreciate your time gloria allred thank
you so much for joining the show it's my
pleasure thank you so much
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy Boren associate producer Colton
Haas
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Mader
post-production is supervised by Alex
zingara editing by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
pedal graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 before we go I just want to give you
an important update on next year's
edition of The Sunday special the sunday
special will be returning to your
podcast feeds on March 1st 2020 will be
delivering thirteen straight weeks of
bold exciting interviews with iconic
guests so hang tight for new episodes
this March because we've got some great
things planned out for you we've had an
amazing year full of terrific interviews
with guests like dave ramsey dr. phil
andrew yang neil degrasse tyson nikki
Haley piers morgan and more and we're so
excited to bring you another fantastic
lineup coming March if you haven't seen
any of these great episodes yet check
out the Sunday special at daily wire.com
the daily where a YouTube channel or
anywhere you get the Ben Shapiro show
podcast so again the Sunday special will
be returning to your podcast feeds
social media channels and daily we're
calm on March 1st at 20/20 so mark your
calendars the best is yet to come see
you there